we are starting today with the United
States Senate we still don't know who
controls it we still don't know who will
control it but there is going to be a
runoff in the state of Georgia on
December 6th between Raphael Warnock and
Challenger Herschel Walker this may be
the race that decides who controls the
Senate let's set it up and tell you
where we are right now at this point in
time based on the seats that have been
determined definitively it is Democrats
48 and Republicans 49 in the Senate
remember Democrats need only 50 for a
majority because Kamala Harris the vice
president would be the 51st vote a
tiebreaker in the event of any 50 50
Deadlock it is quite possible
it is possible that Democrats won't
actually need Georgia why do I say that
well in Arizona Mark Kelly the incumbent
Democrat is five points ahead of Blake
Masters the uh horrible Republican
Challenger with 76 percent of the vote
in is it possible Masters could still
win there it is is it likely no this
race when it is hopefully called for
Mark Kelly will put Democrats at 49. you
then have the state of Nevada
in Nevada the incumbent Cortez masto is
running 1.8 points behind Adam laxalt
but experts who are looking county by
county at what is outstanding in Nevada
say this may end up being a defeat for
Adam laxalt because even though 84
percent of the vote is counted the 16
percent that is left favors Cortez
Master the question is will it favor her
enough for her to make up 1.8 points we
don't know the answer
if indeed Cortez masto pulls this out
that's 50. and the Georgia race becomes
for 51 which would make Kamala Harris's
tie-breaking vote unnecessary but we
can't count on that it is totally
plausible that control of the Senate
will depend on a December 6 runoff in
Georgia why is there a runoff if you
look at the results Rafael Warnock won
well Georgia has what's called the 50
threshold rule If no candidate gets to
50 percent a runoff will be held between
the top two candidates and indeed
because there is a third party candidate
in Georgia Oliver who got a hair over
two percent of the vote although Raphael
Warnock won by 1.3 points nearly 50 000
votes there will be a runoff this is the
race
in which we must now get involved I
don't know that I can make it down to
Georgia in the next few weeks but we are
going to try to see what we can do at a
distance can we do live streams
fundraising for Raphael Warnock and
maybe get matching funds set up well
we'll take a look
can we do some kind of live group Mass
phone banking or at least get people
signed up to phone bank or something
like that we're going to see what can we
do this is a race of critical importance
there is a dramatic difference between
Democrats losing the House and Senate
versus Democrats keeping the Senate but
losing the house yes if Democrats lose
the house they'll probably try to file
articles of impeachment against Joe
Biden they'll obstruct they'll do a
whole bunch of stuff but in particular
when it comes to federal judges
potentially a Supreme Court Justice over
the next two years we don't know
control of the Senate is absolutely
critical so if you live in Georgia
make sure that you're going to vote in
this one your vote quite literally could
decide who controls the senate for the
next two years and who controls the
Senate at the time of the 2024 election
could also impact that presidential race
so we're going to have much more about
this but that is where we are
Herschel Walker
right up there is one of the worst
candidates I've ever seen can barely
speak
can barely explain his position on any
issue a complete and total hypocrite
says he's against abortion in all cases
urged and paid for multiple women to
have abortions says we need you know uh
we we need we need fathers involved in
their kids lives is an absent father
himself pulled out a fake badge during a
debate has no qualifications whatsoever
has no business whatsoever being in the
Senate this is not only about control of
the Senate to some degree this is also
about reducing the level of humiliation
of the United States globally I get
emails from people all over the world
Germany UK Ireland Australia saying
David what is wrong with the United
States
a guy like Walker should be laughed off
any of these stages in no other country
would he even stand a chance and I think
generally speaking those people are
right let's now talk about Lauren bober
Lauren bobert is pleading the blood of
Jesus to try to win her race what the
hell am I talking about I don't even
know let me reset the stage there are
there is a triumvirate of Maga people
one of whom has already lost I'm talking
about Marjorie Taylor green Madison
cawthorne Lauren bober these three are
sort of like emblematic they are the
prototypical whacked out Maga candidates
that don't have any business being in
the House of Representatives Marjorie
Taylor green easily won re-election on
Tuesday
however Madison cawthorne lost his
Republican primary months ago and is
being removed after just one term Lauren
bobert is number three and indeed she
may lose when we go and take a look at
Colorado and we look at that Third
District you will see that as of this
moment Adam Frisch the Democratic
Challenger is 64 votes ahead of Lauren
bober that is a razor thin margin we
don't yet know for sure who will win but
what we have been told is that the
remaining ballots that five percent of
the vote that is outstanding favors Adam
Frisch and that it is plausible while
certainly not a guarantee that Lauren
bobert would be defeated here is
something really wacky and I don't even
know what this means Lauren bobert said
that they are pleading the blood of
Jesus to try to win this was at the end
of her event on Tuesday night at which
point her confidence level was a little
lower than it was at the start of the
night that's for sure name of Jesus I
just I just before these people they are
so precious God we plead the blood
over our elections father God I thank
you there's a hedge of protection I give
you God for everything that you are
doing I don't know what it means to
plead the blood of Jesus I genuinely
don't know what that is that a good
thing or is it a bad thing
[Music]
is in office because you are Keen well
if it doesn't matter then I don't even
know why bobert is running but that's
maybe a question for a different day
is there something wrong with me that
I'm enjoying seeing her uh potentially
lose and and just lose it in this way is
that something that I should be
exploring in therapy that I'm taking
such pleasure in her potential
Misfortune or is it logical given how
horrible and humiliating a person she is
earlier in the night she was much more
confident she said it was all trending
in her Direction but judging from the
Applause it's not even really clear the
crowd believed it but I am so optimistic
yeah it is absolutely trending in our
favor as Ben has told you the New York
Times is still saying congresswoman
Lauren Boer is very likely to win
now the truth is the New York Times
stopped updating those predictive uh
tools that they had a few hours into the
night and it was really worth nothing at
that point in time I don't want to
celebrate too early because Lauren
bobert may win but if indeed some of the
analysts who really know Colorado are
right who are looking county by county
if indeed she does lose it will be a
great thing in all likelihood and again
when we look at the numbers if we go
back from Colorado
and we go to the map right now you need
218 seats to control the House of
Representatives right now Democrats have
191 and Republicans have 209 it is still
definitely the most likely outcome that
Republicans will control the house but
controlling it with Lauren bobert and
Madison cawthorne both losing their
first term after their first terms is a
much better scenario and when we
consider that triumvirate green
cawthorne bobert removing two-thirds of
it is a beautiful thing we're going to
take a very quick break we have a packed
program for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David packman show is an audience
supported program I can't tell you how
flattered I am at the nearly 2 500
people who got either website
memberships or twitch subscriptions in
the five days leading up to the midterm
election we did a membership Drive
during our live streams the goal was
initially a thousand then we upped it to
two thousand we upped it to 2500 and got
to about 22.50
unbelievable unbelievable and I would
love for you to join in get the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad get
access to the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show get the
invites to the members only Town Hall
events and so much more and do it while
supporting Independent Media the coupon
code 24 starts now is live and it's live
because 24 has clearly started you can
sign up at joinpakman.com let's now talk
about 2024. I spoke last week with
Angelo carouson for Media Matters and we
talked about the escape hatch that
right-wing media and many Republicans
have set up for themselves when it comes
to Donald Trump in 2024. it looks as
though the Murdoch family through news
corporations the New York Post is
pulling the ripcord on the escape hatch
publishing a front page piece Trump de
Dumpty depicting Donald Trump as a
swollen headed Humpty Dumpty saying Don
who couldn't build the wall had a great
fall can all the gop's men put the party
back together again this is a piece it's
an opinion piece in the New York Post by
John pedorets and John pedoritz calls
the piece here's how Donald Trump
sabotaged the Republican midterms or
whoever picked the title called it that
often it's not the writer and points out
that Donald Trump has had three
consecutive elections in which he has
arguably been a drag if not a downright
disaster for the Republican Party think
of it Donald Trump won the presidency in
2016 riding on a number of different
things that included of course James
Comey opting to do a second press
conference to talk about Hillary Clinton
for some reason we still haven't figured
out and many other factors Trump won in
2016 genuinely he really won
2018 didn't go nearly as well for
Republicans as historically maybe it
should have 2020 Trump straight up lost
and they lost everything they lost the
house the Senate and the and the White
House in 2020 and now in 2022 I know
Trump is saying oh I'm 215. I have two
200 endorsements I got right and 15 I
got wrong but as I've told you before
it's very easy to run up the score when
you're mostly endorsing incumbents and
republican nominees in safe red
districts but on the critical races that
would make a difference Michigan
Governor Pennsylvania Governor
Pennsylvania Senate
um Georgia Senate we have the list right
um Trump's record is not very good in
2022 and Rupert Murdoch and his family
seem to be saying we're out couple
different things that are important to
think about here my concern with all of
this I don't really care I don't care at
all about the Murdoch family news
corporation Fox News the internal
deliberations of the Republican Party
Ronald McDaniel I don't care about any
of these people I think they're all
horrible I think it's a misguided
movement my concern is what would be the
most damaging scenario to themselves how
can they themselves damage themselves
the most
is it Trump announces on Tuesday that
he's running for president and everybody
gets out of the way
does that now lead to two years of human
further humiliation and another big loss
in 2024. if that's the worst case
scenario for Republicans that's the one
I want
on the other hand is a very
snipey and and a sort of a low brow
battle between Trump and DeSantis for
the Republican party for the next two
years the most damaging thing to
Republicans which will weaken them and
make them crumble and erode such that
they get crushed in 2024. that's my
concern whatever is the worst thing for
them is what I want to see happen right
now
it seems as though the infighting is
good for the left and good for Democrats
and Trump is already attacking Ron
DeSantis we'll talk about that a little
bit later and there are many reasons to
think that the Murdoch's now feeling
free to pull the rip cord is a good
thing we're going to talk about this
plenty more we're linking to the piece
by John pedora it's I know it's the New
York Post but the whole point is it's
interesting to see how even they now are
portraying Trump and specifically I now
want to talk about Pennsylvania
there's a really good article in slate
by Jeremy Stahl called the total
humiliation of Dr Oz and Trump in
Pennsylvania and there's a couple of
different perspectives about what took
place in Pennsylvania but a great
starting point is this article by Jeremy
Stahl and Jeremy Stahl points out most
importantly fetterman beat new
jersey-based crudites a loving TV
celebrity Dr Mehmet Oz and Stahl
correctly points out it wasn't a
guarantee
fetterman ran several points behind the
winning Democratic gubernatorial
candidate Josh Shapiro it's easy to
imagine that a strong Republican
candidate could have beaten fetterman in
a race that may well determine control
in the Senate indeed Republicans had a
real opportunity to select that strong
Challenger specifically the relatively
moderate hedge fund manager and former
Treasury Department official David
McCormick who finished second in the
Republican primary by just 951 votes
Stahl makes the case and I believe he's
right that were it not for Trump's
endorsement of Oz McCormick would have
won the primary and it is completely
plausible that if McCormick wins the
primary he defeats fetterman it quite
literally if the Senate ends up 50 50 in
favor of Democrats because of Kamala
Harris as the tie-breaking vote you
could accurately blame Trump for losing
Republicans the Senate by jumping in and
endorsing Oz rather than McCormick or
staying out of it altogether
a couple of different things here
one of the aspects to this race that got
very ugly was essentially the stroke
shaming that took place by many
Republicans after John fetterman
suffered a stroke months ago
and struggling with auditory processing
not cognitively but struggling with
auditory auditory processing the Oz
campaign uh put out some ads ridiculing
fetterman's Health although Oz
personally said it wasn't me doing that
but it was still attached to the
campaign
um at the debate
even some of my viewers never mind the
Republicans we're kind of making fun of
fetterman for the way that he was
speaking and
one of the crazy things is you know they
were out there calling him and I I
apologize for these terms they were
saying he he's he's a [ __ ] people were
saying he based on how he's speaking
he's a [ __ ] uh he's brain damaged blah
blah blah blah
um
he won
okay
at some point
when it came to Trump lost to Biden who
was in his basement
that's not believable the flip side of
it is how humiliating is it that Trump
lost to a guy who didn't leave his
basement right like if if anyone
concedes that that's what Biden did it
makes it all the more embarrassing that
Trump lost to that guy now of course
they say he didn't really lose it was
fraud
put that aside for a moment for all
their criticisms of fettermen which
include just making fun of the guy for a
medical problem that he had doesn't it
make it all the more embarrassing to Oz
that he couldn't beat the guy that they
describe as a mentally [ __ ] person
it should really make them think wow
these candidates are terrible now they
may ultimately start claiming fraud in
some of them are anecdotally or whatever
the case may be but crudite did not take
oz to Victory and to me the really scary
thing is that Oz didn't lose by more
when you look at what happened in
Florida DeSantis won by 19 that is
brutal the polling had the santis up
like 11 which would be bad enough and
ultimately DeSantis loss by like 19 and
that is signaling the strength of the
DeSantis wing of the party on the other
hand
Oz lost he didn't even lose by that much
and he should be glad about that but
Pennsylvania rapidly becoming the
biggest humiliation for Trump and
Republicans and we're going to talk
about the endorsement record a little
bit later just remember endorsing
incumbents and republican nominees in
red districts is not a difficult way to
run up your score for endorsements when
you have actual tough races where the
primary winner might actually affect who
wins in the case of McCormick versus Oz
it almost certainly did
Trump's record is a disaster and this is
why Rupert Murdoch and some others are
pulling the rip cord and trying to get
the hell out of here make sure that you
are subscribed to the David Pacman show
on YouTube or that you've liked our
Facebook page or that you're following
us on Twitch that's where all of the
streams will take place the upcoming
stream in support of Raphael Warnock
will be on those three platforms the
Trump announcement next Tuesday will be
on those platforms election results on
December 6th we'll be streaming on those
platforms make sure you're following
subscribe to whatever it is all
completely free
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to have back on the program once again
Anand girdardas who is a journalist and
commentator the new book is the
persuaders at the front lines of the
fight for hearts minds and democracy
really appreciate having you back on oh
thank you for having me back so
intuitively I have the sense that on
political issues it is now more
difficult to persuade people even when
the facts are on one side and I think
maybe the first place to start is it is
that perception accurate is it true that
there we are in an era where political
beliefs are in a sense more like sticky
or stubborn or difficult to change
I think another way to think about that
is is the is the fraction of people who
are very difficult to persuade has that
fraction of people grown I think that's
in a way what we mean when we talk about
polarization
right that that the country has sorted
into uh these kind of two political
tribes
um but I think part of where the
persuaders book starts is from the
premise that we have confused
polarization for meaning that no one is
persuadable anymore which is not true it
is the case that significant minorities
of people on each side are not
persuadable and what defines that group
on each side and the left and the right
is not how strong their opinions are but
how deeply held those strong opinions
are which is to say you can imagine
someone we all know this person who will
huff and puff about a strong border
right
but you could imagine someone who Huffs
and puffs about a strong border who has
watched
80 documentaries about immigration
policy and reads books about it and goes
to you know militiamen meetups where
they talk about the border that is not a
persuadable voter that is someone who
not only has a strong opinion but as a
strongly held strong opinion you know
that person has talking points to rebut
any objection you might make that person
you know and that exists on the left
also there's people who you know have a
strong stance on Universal Health Care
because they've really they thought it's
part of a world view they've thought
about it they've bolstered it it's part
of their Community uh consciousness
but then there are other people who vote
alongside
the strong border guy or the Universal
Health Care person
who may have that opinion on the surface
but have much shallower roots of that
opinion they haven't watched a bunch of
documentaries about border policy they
have not
uh read a bunch of books they have what
in I think the corporate world is
sometimes called strong opinions lightly
held right and persuadable voters are
people who might have strong opinions
but also have them lightly held they are
at as a notchenkarosoria one of the many
brilliant persuaders I write about in
the book says these persuadable voters
are people who can be toggled into a
very Progressive way of looking at the
world or a very conservative way of
looking at the world to give you an
example on immigration
when
the thing in the air
is imagery of people crossing migrants
crossing the border in Caravans
those persuadable people can be toggled
into with the right messages can be
toggled into a very right-wing
nationalist fear-based close the border
as you will remember a couple years ago
when
family separation
was the dominant thing we were all
seeing on the news every day
a lot of those same moderate persuadable
voters where if you remember using the
phrase This Is Not Who We Are
right those same people who want a
different circumstance might have been
toggled into a very right-wing
understanding of the Border where in
that moment with that set of fact that
set of stimuli toggled into a very
Progressive understanding of the
question and so this book is about how
you speak to those significant numbers
of people in the middle who you don't
need most of them you don't need all of
them
but if you can win many of them in a
given moment in a given election on a
given question it can make the
difference between very different
futures
when people often will call in and ask
about persuasion
whether it's at a dinner table or
whether it's in a national election
oftentimes the conversation is different
and we've talked with people who
specialize in kind of changing beliefs
at what we might call the retail level
which is you build a relationship with
someone that you personally know and
there's often many conversations and
here's the average number of hours that
it can take and that that's sort of like
one bucket the other bucket is widely
held beliefs
for large numbers of people for the
purposes of winning an election and how
views can be shifted in those sort of
situations can you talk a little bit
about with that second group which is
for the purposes of winning an election
with views that might include Trump was
actually the winner in 2020 it was
stolen from him or you know Democrats
want to do abortions when a baby is
already six months out of the whatever
the case may be what are the techniques
that can be used in those sorts of
situations well
the last the the actual examples you
raised are in a way not examples of
arguments but examples of disinformation
right so there's a chapter in the book
that is about persuasion in the context
of disinformation which in some ways is
a separate uh separate question from
traditional you know traditional
political persuasion so and and just to
be clear it's different why because it's
simply based on a misunderstanding of a
fact rather than maybe conflicting
morals or something like that exactly
like if you and I are having an argument
about whether
you know uh a fetus is a
person deserving of legal status and
protection from homicide laws or not
yeah
that's not an issue of you and I having
different
facts or senses of reality like the
facts are broadly agreed it's a you know
whether a fetus is a person deserving
that protection is a moral argument that
depends on you know interpretation and
that and a lot of politics you know or
or just like is a 31 marginal top tax
rate or a 39 percent one going to
enhance economic growth and broadly
shared Prosperity again no one is we're
not you know in hopefully in a good
version of that conversation we're
looking at a common set of facts and
historical data and we're inter these
things are complicated right yeah the
examples you cited really are where we
are now in many cases where it's like
moon is made of green cheese territory
and you know the world is run by a
global pedophile ring run out of a pizza
restaurant on Connecticut Avenue in
Washington DC kind of thing with Q Anon
43 million Americans by the way not
believe in the underlying fantasies of Q
Anon which means 43 million Americans
could be understood to be in a diffuse
dispersed you know uh virtual cult yeah
um so the issue you raise is very
important and
I I spoke to two different experts for
that chapter about what we do about this
problem how do you persuade in the
context of people having really their
own sense of reality that is non-reality
and the two you know one of them was a
cult deprogrammer a former cult victim
herself who got out of the cult and then
helps other people get out of Cults uh
one at a time right and she's now
thinking about what are you doing
millions of people are being manipulated
in cult-like ways by leaders like Donald
Trump or disinformation
um and then I spoke to a cognitive
scientist who works a lot on uh covid
and I mean uh climate and then now covet
disinformation and try to figure out how
do you deal with that and what both of
them said from their different Vantage
points that really surprised me was that
essentially we may need to treat this
information as endemic in the age of the
internet that there's not going to be a
I mean literally a disinformation artist
owns Twitter right now so the idea of
the idea of shutting off this spigot
feels I think to both of them a little
fanciful and what they suggest sticking
with the kind of Public Health endemic
analogy if this is endemic if this
information is going to be in the air
the answer is to inoculate people
against it don't worry this is not like
a an actual shot right but a public
health approach to disinformation is
what they suggest which is essentially
an educational
uh an educational shift where basically
the way you know things like sex ed were
once taught to people in their homes if
at all or people figured it out behind
the barn or whatever now you know sex ed
came to be thought of as something that
was crucial to any child's development
we the the state the society has an
obligation to have everybody have a
common minimum understanding of their
own bodies and sexuality and where
babies come from and and so on and so
forth well I think being able to detect
and kind of interdict these common
tactics of cult manipulation and
disinformation
may become viewed as a core part of an
education today you know critical
thinking is what like here's a passage
of a book you know uh what are the three
main ideas and which ones that that's
not no no no that's quite lacking that
definition of critical thinking was you
know not adequate I think to you know 15
year olds being up against Rupert
Murdoch and we need to fortify them and
to detect
how and when they are being conned
because you mentioned Cults and we've
we've also interviewed experts on Cults
and getting people out of Cults former
cult members Etc
obviously the inoculation ahead of time
preventing people from getting sucked in
in the first place absolutely a great
thing important thing reality is a lot
of people are already sucked in what
methods of persuasion have you seen be
most effective at getting someone out of
a cult so the in the interesting thing
here that I learned again from both
Diane Ben Scott her and the and uh John
Cook the scientist
is that what we are 10 what we tend to
do instinctually when we encounter those
people is ass backwards uh almost
designed to not work and drive them
further into the arms of the Khan what
we often do is make them feel stupid uh
we often uh try to rebut their points
Point by Point haggle on reality present
data a lot of us are you know on the
other side in the reality-based
community are like interested in data
and evidence and we kind of lead with
that
and we don't understand what's
necessarily going on there and so what
both Diane and John educated me on is
basically they view a someone who has
who has succumbed already as you say
uh as someone who there's kind of two
warring forces within them that person
and one of them has is badly beating the
other the first Force is the desire to
have the world make facile sense
we all have that desire every single one
of us has that desire yep
Cults and disinformation prey on that
desire right the world is complicated
globalization is complicated covet is
complicated Q Anon comes in it's
actually very simple right it's
appealing and it hooks certain people
the second desire that is also in every
human heart is the desire to be no one's
fool the desire to be no one's dupe the
desire not to be a mark for the for
powerful manipulative people
and what has happened in people who've
succumbed to disinformation is that
Force number one has really outgunned
Force number two in them Force number
two is kind of lying latent and so the
thing that works is not factual rebuttal
or evidence or making them feel dumb but
helping them see that they may be being
used
by powerful people who are
manipulating them for the benefit of
those powerful people and not their
benefit helping them see the ways in
which they've been tricked to be clear
this is not going to work all the time
it may not work most of the time yeah
but it has shown some results Diane
benskota wrote about her own experience
being in the Moonies and you know these
these deep programmers came and tried
her mother organized it tried to come
and get her out and they were telling
her the beliefs about Christ are not
true here's the truth about this here's
the truth none of it worked what worked
on her she was sitting in this room
and they start telling her about
brainwashing techniques in Mao's
revolutionary China
and what was interesting is she didn't
have
emotional defense mechanisms around
Mao's revolutionary China right right it
was not coming at her straight
it was like exotic a world away right
and so maybe she listened a little more
easily than she might have if it had
been straight up here's why what you're
saying about Jesus is not true
and she started hearing the list of
Mao's brainwashing techniques
and she just recognized them
she just and she started she just kind
of described I think the world like
crashing pieces of glass all around her
as a sensation she felt just and and she
kept muttering herself like what if this
was all a lie and so again I don't want
to unders I don't want to overstate how
easy this is right it doesn't always go
that well yeah but that I think that's
the dynamic you are aiming for planting
a seed of doubt and I would say lastly
this comes up again and again in the
book not just on this information
persuasion often involves trying to
displace what is in people's heads not
trying to replace what is in others
heads and certainly not being perceived
as having an agenda of replacing what is
in their heads simply trying to displace
to make people have questions again so
displaced rather than replace makes me
want to talk about the group of
canvassers you spoke to in Arizona and
how they were focused on changing
people's minds on on immigration what
were they doing
this was a you know of all the of all
the different
people I studied and you know uh tried
the different types of persuaders I
wrote about from these scientists
Educators activists organizers uh these
canvassers in
Arizona filled me with so much hope they
were engaged in this experiment called
Deep canvassing that grew out of the
stinging defeat of gay marriage in
California in 2008 on the night that
Barack Obama got elected right so and
otherwise an otherwise kind of Glorious
night in American history that was you
know that overshadowed this really awful
defeat
by referendum in California in other
words most people's Neighbors
were against
the view of gay people as full human
beings right that was a they didn't know
that they didn't know that that was the
majority view the vote lost L.A County
right gay marriage lost LA County
uh you know what we would think of as a
reasonably decent place to be gay in the
United States gay marriage lost LA
county in 2008 and so these gay rights
activists in the LA LGBT Center and
others were just in a funk and you know
one of them described walking around the
grocery store and you're like standing
in the produce aisle being like
like does this person next to me want to
exterminate me like does this person
think I'm not a person like who you know
it's not Mitch McConnell in like 2 000
miles away it's not people in the
Central Valley like I am surrounded by
people who do not think I'm a human
being
and it you know again this is not for
the faint of heart and it's not for most
people but a certain subset of these gay
activists in
La in that time we're like I want to go
to knock on people's doors and find out
why they hate me
again you may be listening to this
thinking who the hell would want to do
that yeah right and like totally great
to stay at home and not do that but
these people wanted to go do that they
wanted to know they actually had
questions right they didn't they
couldn't understand why people couldn't
understand them and so they went and it
what started kind of informally Helter
Skelter talking to people listening
has since developed into a method that
is remarkable that I witnessed at its
kind of you know maturity in in Arizona
where these canvists go door to door
they don't do 30 second conversations
about have you found your polling place
or do you have a flyer they spent 30 to
40 minutes lovingly patiently
strategically talking people through
their views their deepest prejudices as
well as values that might conflict with
their prejudices they don't they again
displace not replace they don't come in
there and say well you say this about
immigrants being lazy but do you know in
fact David that 25 of immigrants work
900 hours that's not what they do right
what they look for is so you said
immigrants are lazy do you know any
immigrants personally oh well yes my
Gardener Manuel is is Manuel is Manuel
lazy
I know Manuel works like harder than
most people I know and is is he the only
one in his family was like that or no
actually there his kids are so hard
working there like in college but
they're also working two jobs
I'll interest and at some point you just
say to them
how is the thing you said at the
beginning sitting with you as you now
tell me about
Manuel and you just let it you create
the great little silence there for them
yeah and people
you know this may sound either
believable to you if you're listening to
this are not believable but not everyone
has probably thought about these issues
as much as you and I might have and
people listening to a podcast about
these issues might have people stand
there on the door and they're like
it's true a lot of the immigrants I know
are actually the opposite of lazy huh I
wonder why I always go around thinking
they're lazy yeah right that happens
that's real it's true that people will
say a thing about trans people and then
I saw this powerful video of one of
these canvases a black woman uh in
California
talking about her own trans niece and
basically like ragging on her own trans
niece
and then the canvasser is like have you
ever been discriminated against or
treated badly because of things you
couldn't control interestingly as a
black woman in America she did not
connect it to being black she did not
connect to being a woman she connected
it to being like moving from another
city and working in a job in LA and
everyone in her job in La being like you
should you should go back to where you
came from yeah it was just like not from
being around there and she was like that
sucked I just went to work every day and
it just sucked to like I I can't help
that I lived in another city right and
then he's like and how did that feel to
be just seen and treated that way and
and you see this you see it like a wave
crash on This Woman's face like oh
I am to my niece what those people were
to me right you know and so I think this
work of deep canvassing like so much of
the work of persuasion depends on a kind
of faith
that many people if not most
can change can move uh think what they
think in part because of what what
they've seen what they have not seen
where they've been where they've not
been and that exposure and conversation
and listening and empathy can get us
there this is not an argument to go
around knocking on dangerous doors and
you know hoping to be respected if
you're a marginalized person this is a a
book about some people who choose to do
this work out of their own volition
because they believe that people can
change
the book is the persuaders at the front
lines of the fight for hearts minds and
democracy we've been speaking with the
book's author Anand girdardas always
great having you on uh and really great
great book very much enjoyed it and
we're going to link to it and encourage
our audience to pick it up well thank
you so much for having me it's good to
be back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we are watching the real time panic and
collapse of aspects of the Republican
party in particular much of the trumpian
wing of the Republican Party Donald
Trump's former press secretary Kaylee
mcinanny in reaction to the disastrous
midterm results for Republicans
particularly Maga Republicans and some
of the critical Trump endorsed people on
Fox news said Trump should not announce
that he is running for president on
Tuesday Kaylee mcineny is telling Trump
cancel the announcement at least
postpone it because of what happened on
Tuesday and the fact that Republicans
now need to figure out how do you win in
Georgia Mac and Annie also even saying
Trump shouldn't even campaign for
Herschel Walker it should be Ron
DeSantis a very different Kaylee
mcinanny than the one that prayed at the
altar of trump when of course she was
paid for him as it makes sense to do
listen to this and that could go
straight through the state of Georgia
include Trump I think he needs to put it
on pause absolutely look he'll make that
decision he'll make his own decision but
does he go to find advising any
Contender DeSantis Trump whomever no one
announces 2024 until we get through
December 6th do you see the former
president I mean for him to go to
Georgia I I think we've got to make
strategic calculations
um Governor DeSantis I think he should
be welcome to the state given what
happened last night you gotta look at
the realities on the ground and Herschel
Walker we've got to win the Senate
that's it guys gotta win the Senate all
right we'll move on uh now understand
yes to some degree announcing that
you're running for president when it's
not even clear who won the Senate is a
bad look for anyone that is absolutely
true and that's not specific to Trump
but there's a bigger story here which is
it appears as though Trump would not
even be useful to Herschel Walker in
Georgia it's not clear to me in fact let
me put it a different way
it is clear to me that if Trump does a
rally for Herschel Walker I don't think
it helps Herschel Walker at all at this
point in time in Georgia and we're going
to be doing everything we can to
activate to get that get that seat uh
held by Raphael Warnock but will Walker
tell Trump to stay away
that would be interesting to see will
Ron desantisco because remember Ron
DeSantis won by 19 he over performed the
polls almost 2x winning by 19 instead of
I think it was 11 which was the polls
projection
and he's in the neighboring state of
Florida he's way more popular at this
point the betting markets ha in fact
let's let's check what the betting where
the betting markets are right now uh as
of yesterday they looked quite good for
um for Ron DeSantis uh Republican
nominee
uh
as of this point in time
uh it's actually tightened up a little
bit it's now tightened up to santis and
Trump basically leaving everybody else
behind the betting markets now feel that
this is basically DeSantis versus Trump
so it's not clear that Trump would help
Trump may actually hurt this is a race
that Republicans need and Kaylee
mcinanny is saying Trump shouldn't even
announce on Tuesday there although the
event on Tuesday has not been canceled
there are Rumblings that it is not just
Kaylee mcineny telling Trump to hold off
on announcing that he is running and if
Trump indeed decides not to go forward
with that on Tuesday I think it will be
very quietly announced and then
rescheduled for some future point I also
have viewers writing to me saying David
I'm not convinced Trump's really going
to run Trump announced the November 15
thing before seeing the results of the
election now that he has seen them he
might not run now if Trump were normal
that might be plausible as the epitome
of the ultimate narcissist I don't know
that the results will actually dissuade
Trump we're going to wait and see new
report from Maggie Haberman of the New
York Times is that Donald Trump is
furious over his humiliating losses on
Tuesday is tantruming like a child and
blaming everyone around him even his
wife Melania check out these tweets from
the New York times's Maggie Haberman
quote Trump is indeed Furious this
morning particularly about Mehmet Oz and
is blaming everyone who advised him to
back Oz including his wife
describing it as not her best decision
according to people close to him now
there is truth to the fact
as I said earlier that if Trump had gone
with David McCormick rather than Mehmet
Oz in the Pennsylvania Republican
primary McCormick probably would have
won he only lost by 951 votes he
probably would have won I do think
Trump's endorsement gained Oz a little
over 900 votes that's totally plausible
had McCormick won
you might have had a completely
different situation in Pennsylvania
because there were Republicans who said
Oz this guy's a clown he's not even from
Pennsylvania this doesn't make any sense
now Trump saying Melania was one of the
people that told him to do that that's
pretty interesting Maggie Haberman
continuing quote there are people
pushing Trump to reschedule his
announcement next week and several
Republicans have texted asking whether
he will but it's risky and would be
acknowledging he's wounded by yesterday
something that some advisors insist is
not the case this is the point about
narcissism that I made a narcissist you
know we many of us
who don't have these personality
Tendencies we sometimes trick ourselves
into believing you know what this guy
who can't ever just admit you know what
I got I got outrun I straight up lost
once it's verified and and validated
that Joe Biden won and Biden's
inaugurated Trump's not going to have
any choice but to say you know what I
lost and we were wrong it's two years
later and Trump is still saying it was
stolen in my personal life I've had
situations with
um oftentimes it's with pathological
Liars who sometimes are also extreme
narcissists we're in my head I go wow at
this point they're not going to be able
to keep up the lie anymore they're going
to have to just say you know what I made
that up
and they never do they find a way around
it and the way that this applies to
Trump is we all see Tudor Dixon Mehmet
Oz uh Doug mastriano we don't know yet
about Carrie leg you know we're still
counting all
it wasn't a good night for Trump's
critical contested endorsements he has
no choice at this point to just say wow
I really messed up right no he's blaming
his wife
he's potentially going forward with this
completely harebrained announcement on
Tuesday all right last tweet from Maggie
Haberman quote worth remembering Trump
is a grown man who endorsed Oz Over the
objection of some of the people closest
to him and instead went beyond just
endorsing and attacked Dave McCormick
from the stage at a rally yeah it's
important to remember we're dealing with
a nearly 80 year old man
it's my wife's fault
that's what he's going with it's
completely pathetic and ridiculous now
the question is does he heed the calls
to delay the announcement
Donald Trump wasted almost no time
in attacking Ron DeSantis after
desantis's big win in the State of
Florida and Trump is also going after
the media over an election disaster that
he brought on himself there's a good
article in the New York Times called
Trump Under Fire from within Republican
party after the midterms a longtime
advisor said Republicans have followed
Donald Trump off the side of a cliff
Trump flipped out on Truth social which
he also calls truth Central
yeah as you know Trump not only has
gotten his own name wrong he's gotten
the name of his own social media
platform wrong as well check out some of
these posts on Truth quote while in
certain ways yesterday's election was
somewhat disappointing from my personal
standpoint it was a very very big
victory It's All About Him 219 wins and
16 losses in the general who has ever
done better than that remember I don't
know how many times I I have to tell you
this I know Trump and the Republicans
are refusing to accept it he mostly
endorsed incumbents
and republican nominees in easy red
districts where whoever is the
Republican nominee they're going to win
you can run up the score very easily the
16 losses are consequential control of
the Senate hinges on those 16 losses
control of the election systems by
Governors and secretaries of State in
2024 hinges on those losses but Trump
wants to assist 219 and 16. okay here's
where it gets very ugly very quickly
Trump in his next post saying quote now
that the election in Florida is over
and everything went quite well
shouldn't it be said that in 2020 I got
1.1 million more votes in Florida than
Ron DeSantis got this year 5.7 million
to 4.6 million just asking
there is one interpretation of this
truth
and it is that Trump is realizing
the energy is getting behind DeSantis
the strength of the Republican
electorate is Shifting like a storm
coming in and changing the direction of
the wind towards Ron DeSantis and so he
immediately needs to make the case I'm
stronger than DeSantis even in Florida
now if we want to take this seriously
you have to remember turnout is lower in
midterms and gubernatorial elections
that coincide with a midterm rather than
a general election tend to have lower
turnout is there maybe something to the
claim that Florida would prefer Trump
over the DeSantis in a presidential race
sure I don't know I'm not taking a
position on that I don't know if a
primary in the Republican party in
Florida were held today whether it would
be DeSantis or Trump I don't know that
but this is already a full frontal
attack on Ronda Sanders Trump is
reportedly seething about what's going
on with Florida he didn't even invite
Ron DeSantis to his rally on Sunday
choosing instead only to have Marco
Rubio there he did mention yeah yeah
vote for Ron DeSantis but it is very
clear that Trump is furious with
DeSantis another one of these truths
Trump then going after the media
remember it's me me DeSantis bad media
bad typical narcissist Trump says quote
incredible how dishonest the fake news
media is the failing New York Times has
gone crazy so many of the people I
capital E endorsed went on to Victory on
Tuesday night nobody was even close and
they literally make up a story refusing
to write the facts and only quoting
enemies and losers almost all of the
people I endorsed won yet if you read
the story from two trump-hating writers
who only do as they are told you would
not even recognize the truth they truly
are the enemy of the people again
remember the Articles recognize that
when it came to the critical
consequential races Trump endorsed
mostly people who lost in the critical
would make a difference races and then
Trump again restating quote
219 wins against 16 losses in the
general election and yet the fake news
writes only unrecognizable junk no
wonder they are all doing so badly this
is an absurd framing look at all of the
people Trump endorsed who lost Oz
fetterman Dixon John Gibbs lost remember
when I interviewed him he was defeated
J.R Majewski lost thank goodness the
2018 midterms under Trump were not good
for Republicans the 2020 presidential
was lost and then they lost everything
disaster in 2022 so now what are
Republicans ready to say bye bye to
Donald Trump or are they going to try it
again in 2024 let me know what you think
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here's a caller
asking what is quite frankly a fair
question about Herschel Walker's runoff
against Raphael Warnock in the state of
Georgia listen to this
hey David uh this is joffer from the
Phillies suburbs yeah very excited about
Tuesday's results especially with uh
Shakira and fetterman absolutely I just
wanted to call in to ask do you think
that Herschel Walker's staffers in
preparation for the December 6th runoff
are going to have to explain to Herschel
Walker that a runoff can be something
other than what he does when a
girlfriend shows up with a positive
pregnancy test
some post-election levity take care man
yeah uh so I I get the joke I get the
joke in all seriousness a few people
wrote to me and said David do you
genuinely think Herschel Walker
understands the runoff like do you think
Herschel Walker understands okay
you lost
but no one got 50 so now there's a
runoff
and it's only you and Raphael Warnock
and that's why we're gonna do more
campaigning is that something that
Herschel Walker understands I think
generally he understands it
even if the particulars sort of
get you know are able to are able to
evade him we're going to get very
involved in that race that's a critical
race let me know what you think we
should do as a show about Walker Warnock
and uh we will make it happen we have
such a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about a strategy
that Democrats employed on Tuesday and
leading up to the election which is
Elevate election denying Republicans in
other words keep reminding voters they
deny the results they deny the results
they deny the results we have exit polls
now which tell us a lot about whether
that was an effective strategy we're
going to talk about a New York Court's
decision to block Democratic
gerrymandering which is potentially
handing the Republican Party a Lifeline
in retaking the house and uh we've
talked about gerrymandering many times
before we will talk about it again today
and lastly
um women's basketball player Brittany
Greiner who was arrested charged and
convicted in Russia
this is so horrible is now being
transferred to a Russian penal colony
according to her attorneys it is
horrifying what is going on we will talk
about it and we will talk about much
more how do you get access to the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad it's
super easy you go to joinpakman.com that
is all there is to it you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now and I look
forward to seeing many of you on today's
bonus show if not we'll be back tomorrow
with a brand new show
foreign